when working with the cloud many
companies assume you're trading off
control for scalability
thanks to Google clouds new bare-metal
solution you can run your specialized
workloads on bare metal servers with
full privileges while having them
directly connected to your cloud
environment this gives you the best of
both worlds letting you modernize your
applications while still maintaining the
investments you've made in existing
architecture let's take a look at
migrating an Oracle database to the bare
metal solution and adding more
functionality through Google cloud
services when you sign up for Google
clouds bare-metal solution you'll have
two environments your Google cloud
environment hosting your applications
and your bare-metal solution in the
region extension these two are connected
with cloud interconnect giving you a
direct and low latency connection
between them and with all servers
appearing in the same Network construct
let's simplify and break our application
into the front-end and the Oracle
database we can take the front-end and
migrate directly to Google cloud using
compute engine to run on virtual
machines will then migrate our Oracle
database to the bare-metal server the
architecture would look like this with
different subnets for each environment
but still able to communicate over
interconnect the VMS running on compute
engine can directly interface with your
database while still being able to
access other Google cloud services like
cloud storage letting you capture the
benefits of both worlds now let's see it
in action with a sample migration we'll
start with the networking page in the
Google Cloud console where you can see
our current VP C Network for the compute
engine instances now we can head to the
compute engine page to see our instances
and connect to one through the browser
SSH tool since these two environments
are connected we can jump to the bare
metal solution server from our virtual
machine in this case we'll run the SSH
command to directly hop over in addition
we can also connect over any number of
protocols if we set them up allowing
just about any specialized workload to
be migrated before we do the example
migration let's make sure everything
looks good by running top and seeing
that we have full access to all our bare
metal machines resources this is a
physical machine and we're running Red
Hat Enterprise so you can manage
software the same way you do with your
on-premise servers like with the yum
package manager we also have the benefit
of the cloud so we'll use the Google
cloud command-line interface right on
the machine we can run gsutil to
Oracle our man backup uploaded from
on-premise on to the machine after that
we can run this short script which
creates the database then imports the
data if you have a gold image of your
database it's now possible to spin up
multiple dev environments and have them
all connected to your cloud resources
this solution also works for real
application clusters letting you manage
high availability setups now that the
database has been restored let's take a
look at the data since both environments
have direct access to each other you can
run the same tools you're already
familiar with such a sequel developer we
can see here that the database has been
restored and our application can connect
directly once again the interconnect
lets your cloud apps communicate with a
bare-metal server in any number of ways
now that we've seen how you can migrate
let's try to enrich the data with other
Google cloud services
we'll start by exporting the data from
our running database once again we can
use gsutil but this time we'll upload
the file from our bare-metal machine to
Google Cloud storage you could also set
up streaming over interconnect but we'll
keep it simple for now by just using a
file let's switch back to the Google
Cloud console and head to bigquery with
the oracle database export uploaded to
cloud storage it's easy to clear the
data from bigquery giving you the
ability to run large analysis jobs you
can see a preview of the data that's
been exported from the database and you
can even share the table with other
users
bigquery also connects to many other
tools like data studio giving you an
easy way to visualize the data we can
switch to data studio and quickly build
a visual report of our application data
if we had set up streaming between the
Oracle database and bigquery these
reports would be automatically updated
with new data as it comes in in addition
you can also load your cloud storage
data into other tools like AI platform
to build custom ml models by connecting
the cloud to bare metal servers you can
modernize your specialized workloads
with minimal disruption on top of being
able to innovate with cloud services if
you're interested in learning more visit
this URL and contact your sales team
you